hi Ruth Carter I was the costume
designer on like Panther what happens
now determines what happens to the rest
of the world after two Oscar nominations
people look to you for doing these
biopics and they think that you are you
know only wanting to do that it was just
quite the contrary
the Black Panther that's huge you know
the following the fans the
responsibility if their love found out
what was this we could lose our way of
life what do you not I love dressing the
people of Wakanda had so much fun
infusing some traditional African pieces
with modern society we took the Masai
tribe the color of the Masai tribe which
is bright reds and yellows beautiful
colors and I brought the color up and I
also added beadwork to the tavern I
share on the patterns and beads on that
tablet so it would look like something
that could be passed on and passed
life son it is your time queen Ramon
does wearing her shoulder piece which I
call her mantle we printed this through
the process of 3d printing I designed it
to have the look of African lace Zuri's
costume was one of the last ones to be
built as he stands in front of the fall
the strips are bluey
there was probably a thousand of them on
this costume
I have great things to show you it is
lighter and completely will add proof
now Sheree his little sister has
designed him this new suit
it had to be thinner much more sleek so
from a wide shot it looked like a solid
going in you can actually see this
fantastic texture
I think when people look at the costumes
of the Black Panther they're gonna see
so many elements that they're gonna just
be saying oh wow look at any frame and
there's something to learn there's
something to react to I knew that you
know this is a film media where we get
in clothes and we could see details and
textures it's a feast for the eyes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]